langley we do have breaking news this
morning one of the most influential
figures in las vegas
owner of sands corporation a gop donor
owner of the las vegas review journal
sheldon adelson
has died our bianca holman live now near
the las vegas strip with more on this
and his incredible impact bianca good
morning to you
good morning john good morning alex
sheldon adelson he owned
the las vegas sands corporation matter
of fact these properties right here
the venetian the palazzo the sands
convention center
he had an incredible impact on las vegas
from casinos
to conventions his wife miriam adelson
and the las vegas sands both released
statements confirming his death last
night
adelson was 87 years old he had been
battling with non-hodgkin's lymphoma
since march of 2019.
just last week he announced he would be
stepping back from the leap from leading
the las vegas sands to
undergoing more treatment adelson was
the son of jewish immigrants with a
relatively poor upbringing in boston
but over the course of his life he
created a number of businesses and grew
up to become one of the world's richest
men
he leaves behind a huge legacy in the
gaming world not just in las vegas but
also in macau
and singapore adelson created the las
vegas sands which now employs more than
50 thousand people
his funeral will be held in israel plans
for a memorial service in las vegas will
be announced
later at a later date now again sheldon
adelson
dead at 87 this morning reporting live
from the las vegas strip bianca holman
8 news now thank you very much and
already this morning
tributes are pouring in to adelson on
social media he of course was a
billionaire
a huge contributor to the republican
party donald trump jr
put on twitter saying quote a true
american patriot
and a giant among men senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell said
our nation has lost a remarkable
american he climbed from sleeping on
floors during the great depression to
towering over las vegas
and beyond former south carolina
governor u.n ambassador as well nikki
haley
said this online sheldon adelson lived a
true american life we send our love and
prayers to his family
governor sisolak has also put out a
statement this morning expressing his
condolences
uh to the loss of sheldon adelson this
morning at the age of 87. we'll have
much more on this all throughout the
morning alex
yeah we should mention too dr mary
madelson released a beautiful statement
as well
it said it is with unbearable pain i
announced the death of my husband
he was the love of my life my partner
and romance
political activism and enterprise he was
my soul mate so a beautiful statement
from her
and we'll continue to follow that our
condolences of course to the family